vous avez des prédictions fausse c'est
extrêmement dur ensuite de refaire
l'histoire mais je ne pense pas du tout
que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
une histoire de variants qui magiquement
nous envoyer une envolée épidémique
je pense qu'il ya une partie jeunes de
la population qui n'en peut plus a ne
peut plus se confiner qui cd confiné
tout le monde sait qu aucun jeunes de
moins de 30 ans on est confiné à paris
évidemment ils sont dans les
appartements ils sont pas dans la rue
sans augmenter sa provoquer une rue
circulation du virus
et quand ils sont allés voir leurs
parents ils les ont contaminé
essentiellement dans les quartiers les
plus défavorisés de la capitale et de
l'île de france et donc ça a amené
effectivement un grand nombre de
patients en réanimation mais c'est pas
du tout ce qu'ils avaient dit le conseil
scientifique
le conseil scientifique il avait dit
bien variant qui inexorablement va faire
exploser l'épidémie dans toute la france
et pas que dans l'île de france
oui mais jean bessière ou lire agir ben
oui pour répondre à la question il fait
le bon choix encore faut-il qu'il y ait
un choix or le problème c'est qu'il ya
pas le choix quand vous n'avez pas de
lits de réanimation et quand vous n'êtes
pas suffisamment de vaccins vous n'avez
plus le choix
donc ils ont pris la seule solution la
solution de l'échec
la solution à bouger la solution de
l'échec bat bien sûr mais ce que quand
on voit les la comparaison assez
dramatique et l'ouverture de tous en
israël
le jour où nous nous faisons excusez moi
je crois que les le gouvernement a tout
simplement perdu le contrôle de
l'épidémie parce que on a beau se
comparer dans le premier ministre ce
soir c'est quand même curieux
il a comparé la france à aux autres pays
européens
comme si le reste du monde avait pas
connu l'épidémie pour cause l'union
européenne évidemment il est la zone la
plus touchée est la france dans cette
zone là et est également celle le pays
qui au maximum le mois et où on fait les
moins de performance pour lutter contre
contre le comider moi je voudrais
souligner quelque chose c'est que depuis
le début le seul critère qui qui dirige
la politique du gouvernement c'est
effectivement la tension en réa
sauf que depuis le début il n'y a rien
qui a été fait pour augmenter lé kapab
les capacités animations donc vous
prenez un critère pour décider d'un
confinement ou pas qui est le nombre de
lits disponibles en réanimation
sauf que depuis un an aucune politique
n'a été menée pour accroître et je me
rappelle d'une conférence de presse
d'olivier vers ans le 27 août 2020 que
j'invite les téléspectateurs à regarder
où il disait que si jamais on avait une
autre vague de
de contamination on pouvait monter
jusqu'à 12 8 lits de réanimation
ils sont où les 12000 lilas ils sont
passés ou donc aussi ce là dessus on
nous a menti on nous a menti sur elle et
on a menti également soreli moundir
qu'est ce que vous répondez à un jean
mathia que c'est pas quand on est au
front quand on fait le procès du général
c'est à dire que là il faut qu'on pense
à toutes les familles qui viennent
d'apprendre qu'elles vont avoir quatre
semaines extrêmement dur là on parle de
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
français
may à partir de demain vont devoir
réorganiser leur vie c'est très lourd
bah j'en fais en dit long métrage humant
les jeunes que c'est trash pour les
jeunes c'est trash pour les familles
c'est très compliqué ce qui va se passer
quoi lits de réanimation s'il vous plaît
mais c'est quoi un livre l'animation
sont même pas je voudrais vu que chacun
qu'avec vous me parlez tous de l'avant
la mauvaise vie qu'ils sont en couple
par les dessins animés avant la
polémique et de vos chiffres que donc
vous voulez pas me disent que ses
qualités d'animation et j e me parle des
gens donc j'arrive on ira voir quatre
semaines très dures en famille et il ya
eu une volonté c'est que ce confinement
sans parce qu'on a connu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
là il ya quelque chose de nouveau qu'il
a fallu entendre mais je suis d'accord
j'écoute avec vous les annonces c'était
compliqué c'est long il y avait beaucoup
d'informations oui et donc et on va on
va être chez soi mais on pourra sortir
et on pourra sortir sans dire sans
limite de durée
il aura le couvre feu le soir mais bon
ça c'est ce un quart d'heure mais sorti
pour regarder les ars vous dites c'est
l'une des choses les plus dures pour les
familles et pour les jeunes c'était de
ne pas pouvoir sortir hier à raison
mounir sont nés à l'extérieur
bah oui mais vraiment c est moi je suis
le bien qu'on aborde le sujet des
restaurateurs je me suis obligé de
devenir peut-être décisif aujourd'hui on
a envie on envie de lutter contre ce
virus si on a tous envie de sortir de
cette merde mais ce soir on répond d'une
façon particulière s'il vous plaît juste
pourquoi
au moins les terrasses puisque les gens
peuvent sortir juste le mec qui peut se
poser un casse avait bien boire une
bière qui boit une limonade
la première chose sinon si la mode
j'aime les mecs à coca cola sur toile
c'est ce qu'il est au fait des succès
importants aujourd'hui et ce qui est
encore plus important ce soir après les
chiffres qui ont été présentés vous
pouvez ne pas être d'accord avec les
chiffres
il est est ce que c'est les libraires
c'est pas que les leaders musulmans d
le chiffre il est plus compliqué que ça